so to give you a taste this afternoon of
our brain mind learning efforts we have
four outstanding paddles who come from
three different colleges and departments
at Carnegie Mellon psychology biology
and human-computer interaction I'm going
to begin I'll be introduced them very
briefly and then ask each of them to
talk for two minutes just two minutes to
give us a taste a facet of some of their
interesting research and then I've
prepared a couple questions to get the
ball rolling and we'll have a panel
discussion so the full BIOS of our
faculty are in your program and I won't
do them justice I'll just introduce them
quickly in alphabetical order Justine
casal is the department head of
human-computer interaction Institute
which is a department in our school
computer science and I can't tell you
how pleased we've been to have lured
Justine here as head just as past year
she previously was at Northwestern and
before that at MIT Marcel just is the do
hebb professor of psychology and the
director of the Center for cognitive
brain imaging Michael tar who just this
afternoon had his so-called east of the
Mississippi chair ceremony we had a
similar one in Santa Fe last spring is
as of an hour ago the George a and Helen
Dunham Cowen professor of cognitive
science he's a professor of psychology
his co-director of the Center for the
neural basis of cognition we were also
extremely pleased for Michael to be at
CMU he came here just two years ago and
previously he was at Brown University
and before that at Yale Nathan urban who
also received his chair just today is
now that dr. Frederick a schwartz
distinguished professor of life sciences
and he's also head of our department of
biological sciences so I'm going to turn
this over for now to the panelist will
tell you in two minutes something about
your their research and Mike will start
with you the two minutes tell you
something on because both earlier today
actually talking to Marcel and they
reference to he and I being old dogs and
learn new tricks and I'm not very like
the that / 2 description of the two of
us but uh we were both cognitive
psychologists who study behavior is mark
alluded to and then there was this new
development called functional magnetic
resonance imaging and it allows you to
peer inside the human brain in action
while people or I think thinking feeling
perceiving and so on and the fMRI as a
tool was remarkable so it's really
changed the way we think about research
and think the way I thought about my
research so actually the cue the next
slide another slide one of the things I
was interested in studying is how people
learn about and perceive and understand
identify human faces one of the most
important things we do now it turns out
that there's a part of your brain that
we were able to see which is sort of
right here in your brain it's about key
side they're very small chunk of your
brain by the size of P that is highly
responsive to human faces above and
beyond almost anything else you can go
to it so that's a pretty remarkable fact
in itself it seemed to be such
specialization in the brain and yet that
didn't seem satisfying well it's a spot
in the brain for recognizing faces what
does that mean and at Carnegie Mellon we
know we don't like s places like that
they're too pat we want to explain the
computational basis and so on I was
curious about this we ended up showing a
lot of different things that people are
trying to understand how the system work
so I've given you some examples here in
this picture what doesn't even show to
people is if you take people that are
obsessed with working recognizing birds
and forty years in the field every
Sunday looking on identifying different
birds so it turns out that the same
little spot of the brain is very very
active if you put them in an fMRI
scanner and you look at how to look at
bourbon and so it's not just about faces
offer about birch if you happen to like
birds now if you take people that are
BMW buffs that quote a BMW car shows and
collect BMWs and so on so I can tell you
about feels other original wheels are
not on a BMW and you show them the mws
in the scanner well lo and behold that
same little spawn the brain lights up
for bmw's now i can tell you also that
we never once found someone that both
happen to be a burger and a BMW air
so there was a perfect association
between the spots in the brain between
those three groups of subjects and then
the most fun thing we ever try was we
took these weird little purple things
called rebels which are the only
stimulus etogo that have their own with
the PDA okay and we train people over a
period of 10 hours to recognize that
name these purple things and they would
learn silly names like chemo and depo
and so on and people really learn the
mighty showed someone who had been
trained to recognize these things who
hasn't seen them for 10 years I happen
to give a talkative University and I put
up the pictures of the greebles labeled
he said the labels are wrong that's not
P mu that's jakku okay so they really
learned them well and it turns out if
you take these people after 10 hours of
training lo and behold that same spot in
the brain seems to be very active when
they learn to recognize and identify
these individual objects that they
beforehand didn't know anything at all
about so the more interesting story that
there's a part of your brain it isn't
about face recognition really it's about
being a motel things that look very
similar apart very well and no matter
what it is you're interested in you can
learn to do that it gives us a great
window into the plasticity and the
learning that the brain can really do so
that's my sort of short story that
hopefully remember and I'll turn it over
it Nathan so so given them today's topic
is building a better brain but one way I
can describe my work is that we're
interested in understanding the building
blocks of grades so we're interested in
my lab and other some of my colleagues
are interested in understanding how the
cells that make up your brain work cells
called neurons how the connections
between those cells provide a give rise
to the circuits that eventually give
rise to the function of your brain we
have many different approaches to this
and our approaches is driven in part by
thinking about not just how the brain
works but how the brain confuse what
kinds of things the brain what kinds of
functions computational functions the
brain does well so for example
recognizing faces of recognizing
Greenville's that may be difficult for
artificial machines there aren't very
good face recognizers out there that's
artificial systems and other things that
the brain quite frankly doesn't do so
well I have to add a series of
25 digit numbers I'm going to get out my
calculator which costs two bucks and is
relatively simple rather than trusting
my brain to do it although my 12 year
old son I would have them do it by hand
that's good ring but it's a 1-1 body of
work in the lab that's addressing these
kinds of questions has to be thinking
about really these differences we can
bring some computers in terms of their
building blocks Intel when they go and
make a computer chip they go to great
lengths to make sure that every
transistor in that chip is identical to
the next transistor in the next
transistor biology is messy and sloppy
and biology can't doesn't have the
precision to make exactly the same
building block again and again now this
on the one hand this might seem like a
problem this might seem like something
that has to be overcome for example by
averaging or doing something to
compensate for the fact that you're
making a device with all these parts
which are not quite right but the other
way of viewing this in a way that where
you come to view of my lab is that
having different parts having different
kinds of building blocks can be very
helpful and one way they sort of
dramatize this is to show you two houses
that I made stole my kids llegas so this
is one house I hope everybody can see it
it sort of looks like a house the key
constraint that I had when I made this
house was that I only chose I chose 20
blocks that were exactly the same I
tried to make a house on you it's
roughly it looks like a house that you
know half of you would have guessed
house if I had asked you what the same
point however if you let me choose a
bunch of different building blocks the
same number building blocks but I can
choose from from the whole leg again
which building blocks that I get to use
I can build a better house and so one of
the things that we've been working on is
trying to understand whether the
diversity the heterogeneity that we see
in the properties of the of the cells
the neurons that make up your brain is
allows us to make a better brain to make
a better house to make a brain that has
functions that are more that would be
difficult to replicate in the case where
you're going to make a device by having
lots and lots of car
copies so that's one story about some of
the work that's going on in our lab has
16 or so so my colleagues and I work in
a number of fields using brain imaging
in a tool that's really revolutionized
the way we understand how how thought
occurs we use this to understand normal
thinking and disordered thought
particularly your your developmental
disorders particularly autism and
dyslexia well the last three speakers
have been charmingly interested in
humans so 20th century so 20th century
I've been invited to hold down the end
of the machine but in fact my own
research is not about replacing humans
with machines but using machines to
understand who humans are what they do
that is most human and helping to
scaffold and support those skills that
make us human the example that i'm going
to show you comes from my work with
children with autism we'll talk more
about this but children with autism
often have trouble with social skills
I'm going to show you a short video of a
girl with autism playing with the same
age typically developing here and then
that same child with autism playing with
a virtual peer watch carefully to look
at how good at social skills that child
with autism is you'll see the setup that
we always use with children there's no
adult in the room because children
behave
really when adults or present we take
children in pairs because as researchers
of autism often say when you seen one
piles of autism you've seen one child
with autism and so we compare one child
with autism playing with somebody you
know from school to that same child
playing with a virtual child we've built
an artisan an intelligent systems with
the knowledge of how to tell stories and
how to respond to training storytelling
with a particular goal of scaffolding or
supporting the social interaction aspect
of storytelling why is this important
it's particularly important because for
children with high-functioning autism in
the u.s. today we mainstream easily put
the in mainstream pastors with other
coach and in the United States learning
takes place and collaboration with one's
friends all of learning is about
collaboration passes through calebrage
but for a child with high-functioning
autism we may be able to speak but can't
collaborate can't engage in social
interaction it's not just loneliness
that's a danger but all of Education and
so the question we have to ask is how
can we help that child learn those
social skills in such a way that she can
acquire a sense of other people and the
joys that other people bring us but also
the cognitive benefits that come from
education it's fascinating Marcel you do
some work off and also in these domains
yes as you can imagine we ask people
with high-functioning autism and control
subjects to do some of these tasks in a
scanner and we find ways of presenting
avatars animations the kinds of God's
community to that just being described
and we want to know what's different
about the way the brain functions and
autism and I can explain it we through
the use of imaging techniques we've been
able to develop an in theory that
explains some of the Enigma of autism I
can have slide 12 first of all the top
guy of a 30 second
lecture on the function when you think
no matter what it is adding two digits
remembering where your car's parked it's
always a set of areas that activates
maybe 15 20 years in one account so it's
always a network of areas it's a net
thinking is a network function what and
what what's different in autism is a
slight 13 please what's different is
that the areas in the front of a brand
have a difficulty in communication with
the areas in the back of the brain I
have it schematically depicted there as
narrowed pipes you know you could call
it as a float you could refer to with
this lower bandwidth between the frontal
and posterior areas how do we know this
is true two ways one is we can track the
synchronization of the activity between
the frontal and the posterior areas and
it's lower in office systematically task
after test secondly and this is sort of
new revolutionary because we can measure
the thickness of the pipes and
simplifying slightly let's go to slide
16 there's a method called diffusion
imaging that measures the diffusion of
water molecules and you should really
attend to the 2010 these are methods
that have been developed at our new
imaging center really in the mid last
six eight months we can see the white
matter of everyone's brain with that
degree in feel sort of unprecedented
white matter constitutes forty percent
of the human brain and adjust the cables
to connect the various parts of the
brain so the infrastructure of the brain
is what allows the communication and the
various players to play well together
and if you have a deficit in that white
matter it will impede the communication
go to slide 14 I have sort of an extreme
example of the corpus callosum of a
control subject and a subject with
autism now this is an extreme not
usually this big a difference but
they're really can be differences in the
quality the size the integrity of the
white pattern
schism and we are as fast as we can
tracking down the relationship with the
work between the white matter properties
and the thoughts and the thinking
deficits and eventually the genetic
basis for some of these what mattered
deficits so it's an exciting time we're
really taking this enigma and making it
understandable so the Enigma by the way
is that it's only some facets of
thinking aren't paired in autism and
others are kind of not so bad but how
does that happen so is it isn't one of
these that I remember is the first time
I ever saw a brain of an autistic
individual because no standard screen
autism is it a hideous social impairment
and some people think well it might be a
particular part of the brain is affected
because of the social problem but when
you look at those raining babies it's
striking how there are abnormalities the
brain structure liquidus Lee across the
entire brain enough it's really daunting
it gives you a sense of how difficult a
problem is to try and attack the root
causes of it how you might treat it
behavior later Main Street it was
different kinds of neuroscience and
pharmacological agents and so on system
it was really striking to me and yet it
is interesting how some of the skills
that you might expect for damage because
of the fact that you see in the brain
structures they look at numbers still
intact and other ones are clearly
impaired or there's some that seem
imperative the scheme is talking about
yet you do the right thing they come
back so it's really complicated story
because look at the brain is oh my
goodness you know how are we to get it
Nathan probably gingered him because the
complexity of you see of the functional
level is in some ways weird by the
complexity that you see at the local for
genetics of often this is the heart that
we do but the field of neuroscience is
because imagine it sergeant to apply
genetic and genomic kinds of approaches
to try to understand the genetic basis
of autism other disorders and unlike
what perhaps one month hoped for it's
not that the ones you or even a handful
of jewels it seems to do
regulating miss regulated or mutated in
some way the genetics of autism Trinity
incredibly complicated so it's not
surprising to musicians it's a bottom-up
perspective that there are deficits in
alterations in widely across the rabbits
the interesting thing is that it shows
up in these certain ways and global
behavior and I think we have no anything
this is an area I think we'll come back
to there may be questions that these
shift topics just here for a second so I
have two daughters and they seem to send
text messages constantly and apparently
this isn't unusual according to
according to nielsen studies the average
teen text 1742 messages a month recently
a gentleman named grey card st's teenage
daughter Rebecca known fall is Becky
sent 14,500 28 text messages in one
month resulting in a 440 page ATT
wireless phone bill but one thing about
these text messages as you know is
they're often sent and received and
replied to well someone is
simultaneously doing something else and
even I sometime try to do as I'm sure if
you all do more than one thing at once
is all this good for our brains many of
you have things you can tell us about
this so we do a lot of work on
multitasking sponsored primarily by the
Department of Defense maybe you saw the
article impact on your first page of the
New York Times is monday on the problems
of information overload military
personnel it's true in the cockpit it's
true in front of your desk it's for is
true in this technological world where
we've enabled multiple streams and life
is fundamentally multitasking whether
it's child-rearing or cooking or driving
it's it's not one thing at a time and
really the question the neuroscience can
answer is what does the brain do when
but it's based with multiple has to
perform so when you perform a task say
like driving it really activates only
about five percent of your brain and if
you listen to someone speak just in a
conversation that activates five percent
but if you ask somebody to drive and
listen to someone speak the total
activation isn't ten percent of your
brain it's about seven percent agree and
so if there's a hitch hey canyon by both
past and what you see the driving
related activation that you see people
decreases by thirty-nine percent when
the drivers was new to someone speak and
sure enough they have trouble with line
maintenance they hit the vines and so on
this is in a simulator the scan so so we
should be there so neuroscience has told
us what kind of bottleneck there is and
tells us that bottom leg can't be broken
it tells us that with some practice you
can get a little better but you're never
going to completely make that bottom and
go away so all of us are faced by these
challenges whether it's a Provost
performing his job whether it's a driver
whether it's a parent's a student in the
classroom for students in the classroom
we're faced with these choices and you
know in Suttons it's not i'm not sure
the answer is scientific but the
parameters of the decision texas are
scientifically available now Michael was
just mentioning to me how many of you've
been texting while questioning others I
didn't need it you know I mean one of
the things that's striking is I study
perception and one of things I love with
you my peace perception is I show a lot
of the movies and I think that your
entire experience with some sense an
illusion because it seems like you know
everything that's going on around you
all the time and therefore it seems they
can do lots of different things at once
you can text and drive or texted us
until lecture index let's go on and it
feels okay because you your
consciousness is so good at filling in
and not making you aware of what you're
missing in any given moment there's
really striking demonstration to that if
you are very from the perception class
like a place of different things we're
very very powerful salience events can
happen
in front of you and if I have you
attending that something else while
you're watching that event you will have
no idea that and so if people say i
didn't know that person would run gonna
run in front of me i didn't see them or
whatever they do they eat it because the
job of your brain is to fill everything
in it makes the world seem seamless and
shoes all the time which sort of fights
against the problem that you think you
can do lots of stuff it all does seem
pretty so we're always having this kind
of battle you from what our experiences
than what the reality of the limits of
what I write really do so that's the
seamy underbelly a sexier once again let
me take the machines son now why was it
written why was texting invented why is
it so attractive and I often talk say
tell us how terrible computers are for
children and I have to say did you never
call your best friend on the phone two
seconds after you left her in the
schoolyard of course you did many of us
did did you never sneak out well cake
you guys didn't help myself did none of
you ever leave the house as early as
your parents would possibly let you
leave to meet that group of friends that
you had left the near 45 minutes earlier
and the point that I'm getting to is
that technology is not created out of a
vacuum but out of our own imperatives
our own social imperatives I often say
that teens do those things that fulfill
developmental imperatives and the
developmental imperative for a 14 year
old is to have a constant peer back
channel in the face of parental
involvement so they're trying to replace
the parental which they thought was so
attractive at age six and seven and
eight with the pier standard which
becomes increasingly important I think
it's important to remember that if it's
not texting it's going to be something
else that this fills a need any others
on this so um I think many people
including their children take drugs that
enable them to think and concentrate
better than the otherwise feel they
would is there any reason we all should
is this going to be the giveaway I don't
know this is actually something's come
up been raised by number of prominent
neuroscientists the question of
performance-enhancing drugs not in the
Lance Armstrong style but rather in a
cognitive performance intensive and the
drugs that are most commonly used in
this way at universities and also are
drugs like ritalin and adderall drugs
that are typically used prescribed for
attention deficit attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder yeah there's a
question so what's the long-term impact
abuse I think we we have some data about
that because their booze drugs are not
moving and prescribed for many years and
I think it's so it's an open question as
to whether there is benefit that
outweighs that risk but we won't know
the answer to this question without
prolonged investigation and known
something more about the mechanism of
action of these drugs on what they're
doing to the brain that we have how they
affect the build the brain has
experience of this way I mean this is
another funny thing for beyond the
defense secretary medical consequences
and you don't know what all those are
native alluded to again our
consciousness and our awareness of
ourselves not only addition think it is
so everything makes them great to you
and drug in the classroom or whatever
and it doesn't mean that that's us they
aren't your consequences are sort of
meta awareness of ourselves that are
building the monitor exactly what really
stingray that's not good is it something
important to remember that a bigger way
we assess firmly believe me or okay or
what and I also think it's important
that is a difficult for other
individuals that's why we have things
that Marcel was alluding to the brain
imaging and they have other to pull the
rope on foot or cannot be so it's a
really multifaceted question because
maybe it open it really would be dead
fish near this book listing the crows
for the argues everyone be happier there
may go you'll benefit from some ways in
fact of course now we all carry
smartphone get kind of neural prosthetic
or no question we all live off of all
the time we look things up we but at the
same time I think it's important that
that's consequent from the neural point
of view the behavioral and we couldn't
possibly necessarily assess the WD any
others well i'm going to ask like maybe
one more question but then i hope to
turn it over to the audience so be
thinking of questions i'll be turning to
you soon I want to ask the very naive
question as well as a layperson so if
someone were to look in my brain or the
kinds of imaging tools that you all use
it would seem to me there are millions
hundreds of millions maybe billions of
hundreds of hundreds of billions of
neurons these are the texting that's
right who which all it doesn't generate
the electrical activities and I don't
know that I fully understand how your
imaging techniques are able to
distinguish anything within erm except
for justjust wiry fizzing them for
activity and it's any of you have any
way to clarify pers these are a lot of
different approaches lots of we now have
really in the last ten years lots of
different ways of looking at brains we
can look at brains structural you look
at brains functionally by at a course
level of the course spatial resolution
of energy jobs things the size of peas
course temporarily see changes in
activity that take place over seconds
but we can also look at higher
resolution we can look at brain activity
equal human brain activity at the
millisecond resolution to see
millisecond by millisecond and what
areas are active in what areas you know
you can also look with more invasive
techniques at the cellular resolution so
we can identify individual cells that
are activated during performance and
certain kinds of tasks during
recollection circuit events and even now
the technologies move to the point where
in animal models we can
not only record but control the activity
of individual words what are the
striking things mean in this area is
that there are a number of experiments
now you have been done in a model
showing that changing the activity of a
really small number of cells maybe even
in some cases one cell is sufficient to
generate a measurable behavioral change
in the case of a small movement or a
small procedure in the advantages and
this is really remarkable to that the
granularity of brain seems to go down
all the way down to the cellular level
suggesting that if we're going to really
understand what's going on we need to be
able to monitor those at a fine very fun
temporal in Scotia trip are so 11 let me
say that there many phenomena of nature
that can be explained in multiple levels
of this explanation you don't want to
explain a national economy in terms of
you clear particles and so what's the
right level maybe the individual
typically go as low as that
organizations community states and so on
but which is the right level the choice
of levels explanation really depends on
the phenomenon some phenomena are going
to explain at the level of individual
neurons others are going to be explained
almost certainly at the level of larger
collections in neurons making tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands and
it's nice that nature provides this
variety of problems for scientists
working in different levels I would
follow up on that and say that some it's
interesting that that both and and
Marcel talked about a bottom-up and
top-down approach that is mapping every
neuron in the brain moving upward and
then also thinking about functionality
and trying to think about where those
functions are located so some of my work
has looked at how people interact with
virtual humans and what happens in their
brains when they're interacting with
virtual humans as compared to real
humans
this tells me how they conceive of the
task of social interaction and how they
conceive of that object that is the
virtual human and in fact we're looking
now at a comparison between typical
individuals and people with autism our
research so far has found that everybody
is able to assess the social skills of a
virtual human but for a typical adult
that task as revealed by fMRI is more
cognitively effortful they can do it but
they find it hard our hypothesis is that
for individuals with autism they're
going to be able to assess the social
skills with more difficulty but they're
going to find the interaction with the
virtual human easier and so these kinds
of techniques allow us to find out where
things go on in the brain and what the
meaning is of our actions in the world
like that you jump like six um the PC
revolution this is just you know like
this is a pro computer John the easy
revolution wasn't when I vmi Mapple gave
a bunch of computers the university's
when everyone started having one of the
desktop regardless of who they were what
else they were and i think that the same
thing is happening in the neuroimaging
the movie so there's a few years ago
with very expensive and it's limited
access we now have a scanner that
Marcel's the director of the center for
on-campus will albums do a variety of
state-of-the-art training it depends on
humans and the key thing is it's
relatively inexpensive and we get
undergraduate classes using this
experimenting with them playing with
their trying to convert the thing so
it's not just about us a scientist
trying our core experiments and which
was to be doing if everyone keep going
around he's in with you get real you do
understand that they couldn't understand
before this is just a great example so
this Marcela alluded superhighways of
the brain gives the other brain wired up
in a way it does a few years ago we
could have never even had this picture
so there was no way except by dissecting
of range to see these kind of structures
and now that you see in the living unit
and so you can just imagine is engineers
and computer scientists and even fine
arts majors are playing
tapering our machine that we have now of
the plaza to meet all and try and do
think we didn't know before and how
we're going to be able to tear apart do
these type of technique sedation is
really going to be a revolution I think
over the coming years it's only get
better it's only been around 50 years so
imagine on your 30 years from now over
you'll get with this sort of widespread
infusion of technology but acknowledged
it used to be something I'm very
specialized that becomes very common
post is very powerful it's the sort of
makings of revolutions and I think one
of the things as educators of replace
like yeah it's really important that we
get our students to get their hands on
these technologies as early as possible
in the first University students that
have access to computers I'm sure have
an advantage for many years the first
University students have access to my
scanners our genome sequencing machines
are employed you know high-resolution
microscopy or whatever it is that's
really important to get those
technologies into the hands of students
simply known as early as well right so
let me see if we can turn this to
questions from the audience and there's
a I'm not going to just randomly call
what the person who is coming by with
the mic so pimp when they arrive at
somebody that's fine and just the yeah
go ahead and say that my question is for
those of us who are educators of young
children or parents of young children
what do you suggest for us in terms of
maximizing the children's brain
potential those kinds of things and is
technology involved in that in any way
so let's let me of many of you probably
came across reviews of amy chua's book
know the battle in Chinese I thermometer
I think maybe some of you read David
Brooks is response to them and so and
this is sort of an issue of educational
try and child-rearing philosophy so part
of what ieshua is doing is right and I
can tell you about the brain imaging
study that note
see this right you know one of her
daughters is a really performance level
pianist you know that the white matter
in the motor area of people have had
like a fat something like a thousand or
two thousand hours of camo practice the
stimulant it's dead or higher quality
it's because we can change our brim and
the way I can tell the mechanism is if
there's these glial cells of the good
end recite that build up the insulation
of often used circuits so the circuits
become more efficient higher bandwidth
faster and so on amy chua's children
have I'm almost certainly dead or white
and interference David Brooks points out
that that there there are other areas
that are important to be skilled at
social interaction because that takes
practice and is important as well so
chua's contribution is I think high
aspiration level and lots of practice
both of which I think are essential
those aren't wrong brooke says learn to
interact with your fellow human beings
your team members your parents and your
and your siblings I think there's
another important contribution that I
think American educational institutions
have and that is the sort of the drive
to understand to explore to be creative
and I think that need that in addition
to everything else and in carnegie
mellon we encourage that we teach it we
live we do it in an interdisciplinary
way it's not like i want to solve a
chemistry problem i want to solve a
problem i want to understand this
phenomenon of that phenomenon and i'm
going to use whatever knowledge skill is
necessary i can acquire those skills i
think that when we're training the next
set of scientists and technologists for
our country and that's what research
universities do we impart those kinds of
skills that aren't just the knowledge
they have on graduation day but the
skills that last them for decades as
they contribute to their for economy to
society to their industry and so on so
it's not just a research effort its
research combined with education and in
this introducing introduced inary way
the Carnegie knowing of dust so
particularly well I would follow that up
by I'm quoting from a pamphlet I found
in a secondhand store in Boston and it
says don't be scared of the machine the
machine is here to stay don't be scared
of your child your child is here to stay
however the machine is a bad babysitter
don't stick your child in front of the
machine love your child I love this it's
1962 the machine is the television we
have a habit of being scared of new
technology where the definition of new
is anything that was invented after our
own childhood and it's true that we have
a habit of being scared of computers but
computers are here to stay it's also
true that a computer will never replace
human interaction and so supporting our
children means supporting the use of
technology with our own love and
attention that's what console is getting
at it's something that we pay a lot of
attention to here at that home of
developing new technology so let me chip
and who's Gary
I want to pick up on Michaels reference
long ago to a neural prosthesis reminded
me of Kent hender preferring several
years ago to his PDA as the third
hemisphere there has been work on brain
computer interfaces for years or decades
and it's been limited by very limited
bandwidth to the point is really
practical only if for disabled people
are the first consumers of new
technologies because they're good
willing to put up with its limitations
what are the prospects for sufficient
advances in real-time imaging and
understanding the language of the brain
to the point where instead of having to
look up things on your cell phone and go
google them will be able to retrieve
them as it wouldn't hampered them and
instead of having to spend years taking
piano lessons are going to college if we
want to skill we can well I wasn't
thinking to fill I was thinking porfa
seeing it right away tapping it
something yeah funny just riff along
those rights the great question is
multiple things are at one level is here
if any of you have seen the wii or
Microsoft Kinect there is a great brain
computer interface it's actually working
quite well these are these new video
games and they respond directly to your
movements in your actions and so they're
building off exactly the sort of thing
seasons before doing and so of course
people are working on trying to help
people there a paraplegic and of other
injuries and people that have lost sight
don't know more pieces like that the
build interface directed the brain
insert things into your memories I think
we're a ways away from there we don't
even understand what memories are really
form or how they would get into
something like consciousness whatever
this happens to be they were but at the
same time more and more it's going to be
less of the third hemisphere that's
separable and more of an integral part
that way we interact with the world all
the time and as machines get smart and
smarter they're going to interact an
intelligent ways and dissipation and
people to become more and more scheme
and the print of an answer nothing
so far so much easier for machines can
know what we're doing what's happening
in our brain neural prosthesis where by
implanting electrodes somebody who can
follow prosthetic arm and you're
actually sitting two seats away from
somebody who works on that problem Rob
camping so that version of the problem I
think that's where the most successes
occurred in the context of brain
computer interface for helping
paraplegic for public agents the other
direction in order to do that I think we
really need to understand a tremendous
amount about how the brain encodes
information in the work and we're
somewhat lacking in that way yeah there
are some simple examples where that's
that's gonna work out but um that's a
much harder book there was this
gentleman right here yep my name is
Ricardo shows I teaching the school
music and I'm wondering have you
considered adding a music component to
all of your research I can think of
areas of collaboration for autistic
children for example that would be very
interesting areas of perception I have
worked with individuals who could
perceive a difference of two cycles per
second and frequency memory and also
development of the brain I'm not sure if
you're aware of the finished model in
Finland the resources they're discovered
that kids who studied music were much
faster and learning mathematics and
learning to read at an early age being
very practical they gave everyone music
lessons and they didn't really care
about music at per se but what the
results would be well as a result
jinhwan is a very Musical Society
everyone even composes or goes to
concerts or plays an instrument far out
of proportion to what you might expect
from the small population of 3 million
people but they didn't care about that
and it turns out that now Finland is
always one of the top three in
mathematics in the middle schools the
other two of the top three are Venezuela
and will now China is coming up and I
think that you could relate the
achievement and Matt
China so how many Chinese are now
playing instruments and I wondered if
you have any thoughts about that and you
know we do have a music conservatory
here and so there's no and a very good
one there's no shortage of examples that
you could see what are people thinking
when they year or playing we'll think
about music so there's been some
fascinating work looking at the mapping
between musical confidence and positive
wonderful work by Patrick long at
Northwestern looking at the fact that
highly musical individuals are better at
learning tone languages for example
which is a different kind of musical of
contour they're better at recognizing
the pragmatics of positive so in fact
one of the students that I think people
to hear is interested in exactly where
Padma using music to help individuals
with autism recognize the pragmatic
impact of prosody would it be a way of
food strapping into understanding how
particular ways of saying things carry
meaning and I guess the answer is to be
determined being up probably tone deaf
and the very music will be dangerous for
heat already music into my research but
I think the general principle used to
pointed out between relations between
mathematics and music that I think is
very screw the kind of spirit of
research people do at CNU which is that
there's rarely the brain is really doing
one thing and not only exclusive that
thing it's very related in brain
mechanisms that we study often have
ramifications and do many different
things well my examples the face
technical system and some music maybe a
very efficient giving another plasticity
and the great house hang with learning
and how it interacts with other systems
language system and how it may interact
with other regional system I know
actually a problem some other music
faculty good that some of them are
actually very interested in using the
neuro imaging facility have yer to
exactly look at that time for questions
I think musicians have this remarkable
ability group housing uses a remarkable
ability to practice
I think that that is something that many
many students many educators could could
benefit from learning some of that
ability to practice I find that the
students who come to my lab to work on
experiments among the best
experimentalists are students who have
been trained as musicians at some stage
during the career and I think it's all
about the ability to focus into practice
and so on that's why my kids play violin
right yeah this gentleman right here
right right yeah very much I'm wondering
up to what extent to the activities that
we choose to engage our brains in either
maintain its effectiveness or
potentially improve its effectiveness
well I'll take that's one of the four
things active study is how people become
very facile an expert in learning new
domains and there really are a lot of
dramatic Marcello's this to his work
there are a lot of changes happen the
brain is you choose with activities
gonna do and continue to practice
through them it depends to be this rule
10,000 hours become an expert in almost
anything but you can see changes in the
brain after 10 hours of practice but
then it continues onward for a long time
now last couple percentage points is
always the hardest but you can really
see that kind of thing continuing on and
maintaining it by the voices that you
make so there are real ramifications to
give you one very funny example of where
the degree of implications it turned out
that the birders we looked at people who
are really looking burning actually had
a different girl response to faces
another normal individuals now whether
or not that affected the behavior
ability to recognize faces I don't know
but it certainly did have real
ramifications in the extent that they
were out in the wild 40-plus series
looking at birds everything we know
likewise that use of video games has an
effect on the Brandon on other skills so
there are many reasons why we might not
want our children to play first-person
shooter games but it does turn out that
first person shooter games in
facial recognition they improve
multitasking and mothers filament
remember I don't so before I turn to the
last question let me tell you I won't
get there we won't get to everybody but
there would be a very nice reception
after we conclude this panel if you can
continue to discuss with the panelists
but pack for one more one more question
right there I'm just wondering if you're
doing any work with the illnesses of
anxiety panic and depression certainly
this is a topic of interest here i
believe on monday we're interviewing the
job kandi candidate whose research area
is he uses brain imaging the study of
brain function and people will have a
genetic predisposition to depression
can't remember his name right now but
it's Monday and there's a fog clears you
can find it in google and so we're
extremely interested in this also
colleagues certainly people studied
depression of colleagues of the
University of Pittsburgh study
businesses and obviously an important
phenomena it occurs everywhere including
a tiny melon and we're coming to
understand it in new ways using these
methods and we hope the carnegie mellon
will make significant contributions to
that understand that i think one of the
exciting things about this being
initiatives that were at the beginning
stages of deciding exactly what
direction will take what our strengths
will be and certainly applying some of
these ideas that are there's somewhat
idiosyncratic here to questions about
disorders including disorders like
anxiety and depression i think is is one
of the directions that we want to do
well i'd like to thank you all let go of
it go ahead Michael before we go bye
guys
yes I we wanted something for everyone
remember you see the puzzle of the minds
brains we have a little puzzle here
which all the panels have solved marks
on I have not we're gonna find him down
to see a lot of times let me do it no
but there's a good i think there you
have them for you as you're leaving it
would likely as well to fill your
cookies three times I want to make mark
now are able thank you you find families
are just a subset of the many exciting
things that are taking place here in the
areas of rain mind and learning there's
many outstanding folks here in the
audience as well but I'd like to ask you
to join me and thank them for their
delightful discussions